winter school is a unique opportunity
for young researchers from around the
world to come together to learn from
some of the leading Minds in
neuroscience and psychology in the study
of Consciousness and more importantly
really to learn from each other to make
new connections that they can take back
and Spark new collaborations and
insights for the future you need a
diversity of perspectives and I think
that's really unique with what we've
done at this winter school we have
participants from all parts of the world
where they are at as institutions but
also in terms of their background and I
think that's really really exciting to
have a group of exceptional scientists
from different areas really come
together and think about these really
hard ideas get to know each other and
become the future of Consciousness
research and I think that's how we're
going to really change the field